We average one sexual thought every 7 seconds, but sexual energy can be diverted
You're a superstar new Tony robbins. He suppresses people's natural desires strike up the band
You're kind you're funny. You're pretty damn amazing about pete. He's not gay
Call you tomorrow
You're lucky that you date dudes
No, I'm not actually dead serious about that.
If you ladies are ready, let's play a little basketball. oh, really
been shot in the nuts and also dinged in the melon. They're like little quail eggs
We found a brain tumor up against your pituitary gland pressure
It's applied has watched a normal male development, basically you've never gone through Puberty got the penis of Stephen hawking at the moment
I don't want to split hairs, but Stephen hawking could actually get an erection
breakfast is ready sounds cue birdie at 30 going up
He's got the Sunday times rolled up in there
You got help I'm horny. I'm moody and acting a little nuts
Your puberty is happening at an accelerated speed pardon the interruption, but do you drive a silver brand?
Obsession my office now we have 25 minutes
Hey, Pete when I go over would you mind if I pop those on YouTube I have to take a rain check?
People put their lives aside in pursuit of their next morty has 'm orgasm. I don't know you just seem different
Keith you've been avoiding me yeah. oh. Oh just realize I'm late and I gotta go
You'll never get it you can act out, baby
I ain't you know whenever you're born I've been waiting 15 years for him to do that
you